bruce willis that was a a good
disappointment oh yeah tell everybody
the bruce willis story
there's a whole chapter in my book about
bruce willis
he's amazing [ __ ]
by the way carrie the the ch the name of
that chapter should have been bruce
willis
dot dot dot that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i mean the story is
it's a very long story but essentially
i guess bruce like i saw everything
i i loved even his seagram's wine cooler
commercials i
i i was so excited to meet him i was a
fan
like legit and i want like you know i
had been doing my shtick for a long time
so i was comfortable doing my stick and
i
hadn't had any trouble and whatever so i
sit down and
i i had read that they uh had shot this
particular film in hawaii and so i was
like i'm gonna break the ice and show
them how [ __ ] funny i am
and i i sit down and i say all right
bruce
he shot this movie in hawaii right he's
like yeah and he
he's not laughing he's not smiling he's
just stone face
i said so did you get laid a lot
and i did it just like that i mean i was
as
maybe not that stupid but like it was so
obviously the worst
joke that's ever been pulled on the
planet thinking that somehow that was
going to give me some street cred with
bruce
he stared at me didn't move
didn't blink didn't smile didn't twitch
he just
stared at me for what felt like 400
years
oh no like i see death ray
and i could feel everything in my body
just boiling up like
oh my god what did
and he slowly lifted himself off the
chair
walked out
and i didn't know what happened because
i wasn't really sure at that moment
because it all happened really fast like
was that me or did something else happen
i don't know and the camera guys are i'm
friends with everybody in the room
because everybody that runs
it's all the same people all the time
and they
didn't even laugh they nothing they were
all
silent because they were all in shock as
well
and then i sat there for another couple
minutes the publicist from the studio
walks in she's like
okay carrie you are uh your time is up
and um you won't be giving your tapes
but you know
have a great day and we'll see you at
the next one was like
oh my god and so that was it and he
he ruined my childhood yeah yeah that is
tough one because you're like the guy
from moonlighting come on
i mean he was everything to me he was
like the world's most perfect man
and i realized that day that he has
absolutely no sense of humor and he
hates
women so those two things and then
here's the thing
this was like everybody now kind of
makes fun of the fact that bruce willis
has no sense of humor
that uh tommy lee jones is like just
difficult and it's funny now like
christian bale like those are the people
that everybody sort of has the
reputation
like a couple years ago at the oscars
and the golden globes people were like
harping on these guys for just being
exactly that but
uh the they didn't know that then
and so i had to like deal with this by
myself
and all like the complete humiliation of
it and i had no one to talk to because
no one's gonna have any sympathy for me
they're all thinking that i did
something wrong yeah it's like me god
damn it it was him
[Music]
[Music]
you